Donc nous allons reprendre dans Hébreu au chapitre 6 et avec Matthieu on préparait un petit peu les audios de Hébreu et en fait on a vu qu'on a commencé Hébreu en 2020.
Donc ça fait maintenant, alors je ne prêche pas évidemment toutes les semaines mais on avait commencé au chapitre 2 et par la grâce de Dieu nous avons pu parcourir verset par verset jusqu'au chapitre 6 aujourd'hui au verset 10.
Et nous rendons grâce au Seigneur parce que c'est Dieu qui permet que nous soyons instruits dans cet épître.
L'auteur nous enseigne au travers de cet épître dans un exposé glorieux de la personne de Jésus-Christ.
Et pour ceux qui ont lu l'épître aux Hébreux, c'est un épître qui est très doctrinal.
Beaucoup de doctrines sont enseignées, il y a beaucoup d'expositions des vertus de Christ, des aspects de son ministère.
Mais cet épître n'est pas juste un traité doctrinal.
Cet épître n'est pas juste une exposition purement intellectuelle concernant le ministère de Jésus-Christ.
Il ne s'agit pas ici d'un simple échange d'informations, ce que nous allons faire ce matin, ni ce que contient cet épître.
Cet épître est en réalité composé presque comme plusieurs prédications.
Et elle reste pour le prédicateur un exemple à suivre de comment prêcher la parole de Dieu.
On y trouve de la doctrine et on y trouve des applications.
Et on y trouve des appels à la réponse à la doctrine.
Une fois que vous avez été exposé à ce que vous avez entendu, il s'agit maintenant de répondre.
Et les risques de ne pas répondre sont grands.
Mais les privilèges de répondre sont plus grands encore.
Et l'auteur veut nous mener, nous les chrétiens, au sommet de l'expérience chrétienne ici bas sur terre.
De pouvoir profiter de notre communion avec notre Dieu.
Nous avons été réconciliés avec Dieu.
Nous étions autrefois ennemis de Dieu.
Dieu était notre ennemi et nous étions ennemis de Dieu.
Nous avons été réconciliés par le Seigneur Jésus-Christ en qui nous avons mis notre foi totale.
Et maintenant, il ne s'agit pas simplement de vivre une vie normale, banale, inchangée.
Maintenant, il faut que vous profitiez de cette communion.
Dieu est en votre faveur.
Dieu a de bonnes dispositions envers vous.
Et là où veut nous mener l'auteur, il le résume au chapitre 4, verset 16.
« Approchons-nous donc avec assurance du trône de la grâce. »
Autrefois, vous étiez ennemis de Dieu.
Autrefois, comme Adam et Ève, vous vous cachiez de votre péché.
Dieu était quelque chose qui vous terrifiait.
Maintenant que vous êtes chrétien, maintenant que vous avez mis votre foi en Christ,
approchez-vous de lui avec assurance, sans crainte.
Voilà le sommet de l'expérience chrétienne.
Afin d'obtenir miséricorde et de trouver grâce.
Ce trône qui était autrefois revêtu de puissance, d'autorité,
est maintenant revêtu d'une vertu attirante.
C'est le trône de la grâce pour le chrétien.
Et c'est la raison pour laquelle, ce matin, nous pouvons rentrer avec assurance dans la présence de Dieu.
Au nom du ministère de Jésus-Christ, pour nous, nous pouvons nous approcher avec assurance.
Cessez donc maintenant de vivre votre vie de chrétien comme si Dieu était toujours contre vous.
Cessez donc en tant que chrétien de chercher toujours à plaire à Dieu pour obtenir le salut et son approbation.
Approchez-vous avec assurance du trône de la grâce.
La voie est largement ouverte.
Et le public à qui s'adresse l'auteur est un public qui est averti aux réalités de l'évangile.
C'est un public qui a été exposé longtemps à la parole de Dieu.
C'est même un public qui a été exposé à l'essence de la parole de Dieu, à l'évangile lui-même,
et même au ministère du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Et cet auditoire, comme le nom de cette lettre l'indique,
est réservé à des Juifs qui sont dispersés en-delà de Jérusalem.
Mais j'aimerais ce matin rappeler leur historique qui est à leur crédit à cet auditoire.
Ces personnes-là étaient donc des Juifs.
Et ces personnes-là ont connu un déracinement traditionnel énorme.
Le lien générationnel du judaïsme qui liait leur génération, leur père, leur arrière-grand-père,
a été rompu une fois que Jésus-Christ a été présenté devant leurs yeux
et qu'ils se sont appropriés Jésus-Christ comme étant leur Messie.
À partir de ce moment, leur vie a pris une tournure dramatique.
Et c'est ce que le chapitre 10, que nous verrons dans quatre ans peut-être,
c'est ce que le chapitre 10 nous montre.
Ces personnes-là, lorsqu'elles ont compris l'évangile,
ces Juifs issus de familles juives, du judaïsme, d'une tradition juive,
certainement les hommes circoncis,
lorsqu'ils ont compris que Jésus-Christ était le Messie que leur père et leur arrière-grand-père attendaient
et qu'ils se sont attachés à lui par la foi,
eh bien leur profession de foi n'a pas tardé à faire scandale dans les synagogues.
Ils y sont restés les premières heures de leur conversion authentique,
mais tôt ou tard,
les personnes qui peuplaient les synagogues ne pouvaient pas tolérer
une telle profession de foi au sein des temples juifs,
au sein des synagogues.
Et pour la majorité, ils ont dû être éjectés des synagogues,
des lieux où ils avaient l'habitude de se rassembler depuis leur enfance,
des lieux où leurs parents, leurs frères, leurs sœurs se rassemblaient
au nom de leur profession de foi.
Des familles ont explosé,
des frères se sont rebellés contre des frères
à cause de la profession de foi en Jésus-Christ.
Des parents ont vu cette profession de foi
comme étant une trahison de l'héritage familial
et ont rejeté, ont renié leur enfant.
Certains de ces juifs
à qui cette lettre était écrite
ont même vu leur bien être enlevé
au nom de leur profession de foi
parce qu'ils avaient mis leur confiance totale
non plus dans les rituels,
non plus dans toutes les choses
qui étaient présentes dans les coutumes judaïques,
mais ils ont mis leur confiance totale et exclusive
dans le Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Et au nom de cette profession de foi,
et bien même les choses qu'ils ont pu avoir,
qu'ils ont pu récolter de leur main de façon juste
leur ont été enlevées.
Il est même dit au chapitre 10
que certains de ces juifs ont été exposés publiquement
à la moquerie et au déshonneur.
Je ne sais pas exactement ce que l'auteur veut dire par là,
mais ce que nous pouvons imaginer,
c'est que partout où ils allaient,
ils étaient moqués.
Partout où ils allaient,
c'était un groupe persécuté, insulté,
et pauvres parce que leur bien leur avait été enlevé.
Et contrairement à nous, en 2024,
qui avons tout le témoignage des martyrs
et tout le témoignage de l'Église,
eux, c'était la première génération
qui découvrait les souffrances de la foi chrétienne.
Et ils se retrouvaient errants parfois,
rassemblés en groupes secrets
pour contempler le ministère du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Voilà l'historique que l'on doit porter au crédit
des auditeurs de cette lettre.
Et bien que leur zèle soit remarquable
et pour nous une grande source d'encouragement,
il semble que cet épitre a été écrit justement
parce que année après année,
mois après mois,
le zèle s'est progressivement évaporé.
Le zèle qui les a poussés même
à accepter les souffrances,
à accepter le déracinement traditionnel,
à accepter le rejet de leur famille,
et bien ce zèle, petit à petit, s'est évaporé.
La beauté de ce Jésus-Christ
qui les a autrefois charmés
fane devant leurs yeux.
Et ils se trouvent aujourd'hui
dans une position dangereuse,
périlleuse.
Christ et ses beautés,
ils en sont maintenant insensibles.
Et ils entendent des prédications,
ils entendent des enseignements,
mais ils n'ont plus de curiosité
pour avancer dans la foi.
Ils n'ont plus de zèle
pour avancer dans l'espérance.
pour continuer à progresser
dans la connaissance de leur sauveur.
Et ils se disent,
je n'ai pas besoin d'avancer.
Je suis sauvé,
j'ai mis ma foi en Jésus-Christ.
Pourquoi ai-je besoin
de comprendre encore de la doctrine
et à être émerveillé ?
Et l'auteur les reprend sévèrement
au chapitre 5 jusqu'au chapitre 6.
Vous auriez pu être des maîtres.
Vous auriez pu être de ceux
qui expliquent l'Évangile.
qui vont et qui enseignent
et qui exposent
et qui répondent aux interrogations.
Mais vous êtes maintenant
encore des enfants.
Vous ne supportez pas
les doctrines.
C'est un peu compliqué.
Vous ne pouvez même pas
les digérer, les absorber.
Vous vous contentez du lait.
Et voici les avertissements
qui résonnent
jusqu'au chapitre 6 pour eux.
Voici les mises en garde.
Mais ce cœur qui est,
c'est peut-être
la plus grande tragédie,
ce cœur qui est dépourvu de zèle
pour les choses de Christ
n'est pas un cœur
qui est dépourvu de toutes choses.
C'est un cœur qui va s'attacher
et qui va être distrait
par d'autres choses.
Le cœur se remplit.
Et malheureusement,
ce peuple de Juifs,
il semble que,
malgré qu'ils aient fait preuve
de zèle premier,
eh bien,
ils sont attirés à nouveau
par l'ancienne sacrificature.
attirés à nouveau
par les traditions de leur père,
par le temple,
par les sacrificateurs,
par les hommes,
par les anges.
Et ils mettent de moins en moins
leur confiance totale
et exclusive
dans la personne
de ce Jésus-Christ
qui les a autrefois charmés.
Peut-être sous pression même
de leur famille,
sous pression familiale,
eh bien,
ils commencent à reposer
leur regard
sur l'ancienne sacrificature.
Et l'apôtre qui écrit cet épître,
c'est là tout le but
de cet épître,
c'est de recalibrer
notre attention
sur ce vers quoi
toutes les choses
de l'ancienne sacrificature
pointaient.
Jésus-Christ seulement.
L'exclusivité,
la supériorité,
la suffisance
de Jésus-Christ.
Toute cet épître,
pour vous qui dites
la doctrine,
ça ne sert à rien,
toute cet épître
est doctrinal
et sert à ce que
nos affections
soient centrées
sur la personne
de Jésus-Christ.
Il y a deux symptômes
qui semblaient frapper
ces auditeurs.
Deux symptômes
du même mal,
mais qui se manifestent
différemment.
D'un côté,
nous avons des personnes
qui recommencent
à mettre leur confiance
dans des rites,
dans les rituels,
dans des baptêmes,
dans des rituels religieux
et Jésus-Christ devient
de moins en moins
exclusif devant leurs yeux.
Et de l'autre côté,
nous avons des personnes
qui sont malheureux,
bien ayant connu Jésus-Christ,
misérables,
tout à fait dans la peine,
toujours,
parce qu'ils sont toujours
dans la recherche
de plaire à Dieu
et qu'ils voient bien
dans leur être
leur impossibilité
à satisfaire
la justice demandée
de Dieu.
Ces symptômes
sont bien différents
d'un côté l'orgueil
et de l'autre côté
la misère.
Mais le mal
est le même.
Le mal est le même
car ce sont
deux types
de personnes
qui mettent
leur confiance
plutôt dans leur obéissance
ou leur désobéissance
que dans la suffisance
et la perfection
du ministère
de Christ.
Et toute cette épître
vise
à ce que nous
rentrions
dans le sommet
de notre expérience
chrétienne.
Regardez,
considérez
votre souverain
sacrificateur,
réjouissez-vous
en lui,
approchez-vous
avec assurance
de lui.
C'est une tentation
qui est dangereuse
et qui a traversé
l'histoire
que de celui
de regarder en arrière
et de remettre
sa confiance
dans des rites,
dans des rituels,
dans des systèmes.
Et nous avons
parcouru
largement
ensemble
les avertissements
qui ont résonné
pour de telles personnes.
Et Dieu,
d'ailleurs,
dans les avertissements
surtout du chapitre 6,
donne la perspective
divine
de la gravité
de la faute.
Il ne s'agit pas
simplement
d'une simple
distraction
de regarder en arrière
et de recompter
sur certaines rites,
sur certaines
rituels mécaniques.
Il s'agit
aux yeux de Dieu
d'exposer
son fils
au déshonneur,
de mépriser
le ministère
parfait de son fils.
Et comment
pensez-vous
qu'un père
réagira
lorsqu'il verra
son fils moquer
et exposé
publiquement
au déshonneur ?
Pour ceux
qui ont chuté,
et voilà
l'avertissement terrible,
après avoir été
exposé,
comme les auditeurs,
après avoir été
exposé
à la toute-puissance
de Dieu,
après avoir
goûté
au bénéfice
du Saint-Esprit,
à un point
où même
leur piété morale
excédait
celle du monde
et qui finirent
par chuter,
et par ce mot
chuter,
on a bien étudié
ce passage-là
pour expliquer
ce qu'on voulait dire,
eh bien pour eux
il n'y a
aucune repentance
possible.
Voilà la menace
sévère,
le feu de l'enfer
est déjà allumé
et il leur est réservé.
Mais bien
que ces avertissements
soient donnés
à tous,
ces avertissements
ne concernent pas
tous les auditeurs.
Au contraire,
ces avertissements
sont donnés
à l'ensemble
de l'auditoire
pour que les véritables
brebis du Seigneur
qui se reconnaissent
dans leur paresse,
dans le temps perdu
dans leur vie,
qui se reconnaissent
dans leur manque
de zèle
et d'émerveillement
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
reconnaissent la voix
de leur berger
et répondent
par la repentance
et par un renouvellement
du zèle.
Oui,
cet avertissement
est donné à tous
mais ne concerne pas tous.
Il y a encore
un espoir
de réconfort
et d'encouragement
pour les brebis
du Seigneur.
Et nous avons
étudié ensemble
il y a deux semaines
comment l'auteur
maintenant,
après les avoir poussés
à la repentance
et même
à l'humiliation,
vient maintenant
au réconfort.
à partir du verset 9.
Quoi que nous parlions
ainsi,
bien-aimés,
nous attendons
pour ce qui vous concerne
des choses meilleures
et favorables
au salut.
Car Dieu n'est pas injuste
pour oublier votre travail
et l'amour
que vous avez montré
pour son nom,
ayant rendu
et rendant encore
des services au sein.
L'auteur ne veut pas
que vous restiez
sans espoir.
L'auteur ne veut pas
que vous pensiez
que vous êtes un cas
désespéré
à cause du temps
que vous avez perdu,
à cause de l'endurcissement
de votre cœur
malgré que Christ
ait été dépeint
dans toute sa beauté
devant vos yeux.
L'auteur veut
que vous soyez humiliés
par le chapitre 5
et le début du chapitre 6.
L'auteur veut même
que vous soyez éhontés
de la faute
qui est peinte
devant vos yeux.
Mais l'auteur veut
que vous soyez amenés
à une tristesse
qui produit
la véritable repentance.
Voilà la véritable distinction.
Les menaces
et les avertissements
ne sont pas un but
en eux-mêmes.
Ils ont une vocation
que nous soyons
écrasés par l'humiliation
pour ensuite
mettre notre espoir
en Jésus-Christ.
Et ces auditeurs
pouvaient être abattus
après les nombreuses menaces
que nous avons entendues,
les avertissements sévères.
Et on peut imaginer
les doutes
et les questions
que les auditeurs
pouvaient se poser.
Pourquoi j'ai accepté
de me séparer
de ma famille ?
Pourquoi j'ai accepté
la souffrance ?
Pourquoi j'ai enduré
qu'on m'enlève
tous mes biens
si pour au final
c'est pour que je sois
moi-même
à cause de mon endurcissement
rejeté du cadre
de la grâce de Dieu ?
Pourquoi me suis-je
préservé en pureté ?
Pourquoi ai-je accepté
de me séparer
de certaines relations ?
Si pour au final
des années après
à cause de mon endurcissement
Dieu ne m'aime plus
et Dieu me voit
comme un ennemi ?
Et l'auteur
tente ici
de la réconforter
au verset 9
que nous avons étudié.
Nous attendons
pour ce qui vous concerne
des choses meilleures
et favorables
au salut.
Et l'auditeur
n'est pas appelé
à regarder à lui-même
pour trouver
de l'espoir
en lui-même.
Mais non,
tu es une bonne personne,
ne t'inquiète pas.
Ce n'est pas ce que
l'auteur fait ici.
L'auteur n'appelle pas
un examen en nous
qui en réalité
si nous sommes honnêtes
avec nous-mêmes
nous mènera simplement
juste à plus de morbidité
que à trouver
de l'espérance.
L'auteur n'attend pas
non plus
que l'auditoire
de façon plus subtile
se ressaisisse
par lui-même.
Maintenant,
fais des efforts,
discipline-toi.
Ce n'est même pas
le chemin que prend
l'auteur
au verset 9
et au verset 10
que nous avons étudié.
Non.
L'auteur guide
le regard
de cette âme abattue,
de cette âme humiliée
vers le seul être
qui a la capacité
de le reconforter
parfaitement,
Dieu lui-même.
Si vous êtes bien-aimé,
verset 9,
si Dieu attend
encore des choses favorables,
pourquoi ?
Car Dieu,
verset 10,
c'est à cause de Dieu
et c'est Dieu
qui est juste
et au nom de sa justice,
il continue
à vous appeler bien-aimé.
On avait étudié
cette dynamique
entre le verset 9
et le verset 10
en expliquant
que tout ce qui est dit
du verset 9
tient sa source
de la nature de Dieu
et de la justice de Dieu.
C'est parce que Dieu est juste
que vous êtes toujours
des bien-aimés.
C'est parce que Dieu est juste
envers lui-même
qu'il attend des choses meilleures
pour votre salut.
Cette justice
qui était autrefois
terrifiante pour nous,
dont on devait craindre
est maintenant
dans le cadre
de la nouvelle alliance
pour les enfants
une merveilleuse nouvelle.
Je peux compter
sur la justice de Dieu
pour être parfaitement
réconforté.
Oui, Dieu connaît
la dureté
de nos cœurs.
Dieu connaît
le temps
que nous avons perdu
dans notre vie
à être distrait,
à être assoupi
spirituellement.
Mais Dieu,
parce qu'il est juste,
il a inscrit
chacune de vos bonnes œuvres
et à chacune
de vos bonnes œuvres
que vous avez fait pour lui,
il a lié,
scellé
un lot de récompenses
qui vous attend.
Il a vu votre courage,
il a vu votre audace,
il a vu comment vous avez enduré
les insultes
de vos familles
et à chacune
de vos œuvres,
il a associé
son lot de récompenses
qui vous attend.
Combien cela
a la capacité
de réconforter
le chrétien ?
La justice de Dieu
a été comblée
parfaitement,
ultimement,
en Jésus-Christ.
Les attentes de Dieu,
Dieu est un Dieu créateur
et en tant que créateur,
il est aussi législateur
de ce monde,
comme nous l'avons vu.
Et il a des attentes
envers chacune des créatures.
L'homme n'est pas autonome.
L'homme est redevable
envers Dieu
qui est son créateur.
Et Dieu attend de l'homme,
de tous les hommes,
qu'ils soient chrétiens ou non,
qu'ils vivent à la hauteur
de la perfection morale
de Dieu lui-même.
Mais cela a été trouvé
en Jésus-Christ pour nous.
Les attentes infinies
d'un Dieu infiniment saint
ont été comblées
par la droiture infinie
de Jésus-Christ.
Jésus-Christ,
se faisant chair,
a vécu une vie
sans péché,
mais en comblant parfaitement
la justice de son Père.
Il n'y a pas eu
une seconde,
même dans les heures
les plus sombres
de son séjour ici-bas,
où il n'a cessé d'aimer
à son apogée
Dieu le Père,
de tout son être,
de toute son âme,
de toute sa pensée.
Et pour ceux
qui ont mis leur foi
en Jésus-Christ,
la justice parfaite
de Christ
leur est imputée.
Quant à sa justice distributive,
c'est-à-dire,
chacun de vos péchés également
a été comptabilisé par Dieu.
Et chacun des péchés
recevra son lot
de punition éternelle,
approprié,
à cause de la justice de Dieu.
Et chacun des péchés
que vous avez pu commettre,
les mensonges,
l'adultère dans notre cœur,
le vol,
les mauvais désirs,
les mauvaises pensées,
eh bien,
méritent une punition éternelle
parce qu'en réalité,
nous mesurons la punition
en fonction de
la personne
contre qui nous péchons.
Dieu éternel,
trois fois saint.
Chacun des péchés
que nous avons commis
recevra sa juste punition.
Mais pour celui
qui a mis sa foi
en Jésus-Christ,
les punitions appropriées
ont été déversées sur lui,
sur la croix,
de sorte que la justice
distributive de Dieu
est parfaitement
satisfaite pour le chrétien.
Non, ce n'est pas
par nos œuvres,
mais quand Christ nous regarde,
il voit la justice
parfaite de Christ
et il voit nos punitions
qui ont déjà été payées
il y a 2000 ans
sur la croix.
C'est la raison pour laquelle
Dieu,
et voici la merveilleuse nouvelle
pour le chrétien,
quand vous vous approchez
de Dieu
et que vous confessez
vos fautes,
Dieu est juste
pour vous pardonner.
Et nous pouvons compter
sur la justice de Dieu
pour qu'il nous pardonne
en vertu
de Jésus-Christ.
Et maintenant,
nous passons
du réconfort
qu'il vient
de rappeler
dans ce verset 9 et 10
que nous avons étudié
la semaine dernière
à l'encouragement.
Mais comme on l'a vu,
l'encouragement
n'est pas basé sur
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire,
mais sur la nature
et les vertus
de Dieu.
Ainsi donc,
vous qui pouvez
vous reposer
dans la justice
de Dieu
pour conserver
votre statut
de bien-aimé,
et bien maintenant,
persévérez
dans la conservation
de votre espérance.
Voilà le thème central
du verset 11 et 12
que nous allons relire ensemble.
Nous désirons
que chacun de vous
montre le même zèle
pour conserver jusqu'à la fin
une pleine espérance,
en sorte que vous
ne vous relâchez point
et que vous imitiez
ce qui par la foi
et les persévérances
héritent des promesses.
Nous pouvons nous demander
pourquoi est-ce si important
de conserver cette espérance ?
Pourquoi l'auteur,
à ce moment-là,
il vient à peine
de nous réconforter ?
Pourquoi en deux versets,
il passe maintenant
à l'encouragement ?
Et certainement,
même que certains
qui entendent mes prédications
peuvent nous dire
« Loïc, il va encore
recommencer à nous encourager,
à demander d'agir
et à l'action. »
C'est exactement
ce que l'auteur fait ici.
Il nous a humiliés
pendant un chapitre et demi.
Il nous réconforte
en deux versets
et il nous demande maintenant
d'être courageux
et de nous reposer
sur ce réconfort
pour avancer.
Pourquoi est-ce si important
la conservation
de cette espérance ?
Pourquoi cela devrait être,
on ne devrait pas perdre
de temps
pour demander aux chrétiens
de persévérer ?
Eh bien,
il nous est dit
au verset 12
afin que vous ne vous relâchez
point et que vous
vous remettrez
ce qui par la foi
et la persévérance
hérite des promesses.
vous le savez,
ceux qui nous ont rejoints
aujourd'hui,
nous sommes une église
protestante
et en tant que protestants,
nous sommes allergiques
à toute doctrine
qui mêle
les œuvres
au salut.
Toute doctrine
qui a même l'apparence
d'une religion,
qui a l'apparence
d'une piété,
mais qui inclut
une once de mérite
pour avoir le privilège
de communier
pour l'éternité
avec Dieu trois fois saint
est pour nous un scandale
et pour nous une hérésie.
Quand bien même
vous ajouterez Christ
dans ses doctrines,
dès lors que vous ajoutez
une once de mérite,
que ce soit
eh bien,
il faut que je me fasse baptiser
ou il faut que j'aille
faire tel pèlerinage
ou il faut que je m'adresse
à tel ou tel saint
pour avoir le salut.
Dès que vous ajoutez
les mérites à la grâce,
vous êtes en dehors
du cadre de la grâce.
Cela est encore plus probant
dans d'autres religions.
Il faut que je ne mange
pas de porc,
il faut que je ne boive
pas d'alcool
et comme ça,
j'irai au paradis.
Toutes les religions
sont basées
sur une forme de mérite.
La religion chrétienne
est exclusive.
elle est seule
de son côté
en disant
ce n'est pas par vos œuvres
que vous êtes sauvés
mais c'est par la foi seule
en celui qui accomplit
tout ce dont vous aviez
besoin d'accomplir
et celui qui a reçu
dans son corps
toute la punition
que vous méritez.
Voilà la foi chrétienne.
En revanche,
ici,
de façon assez étonnante,
l'apôtre dit
de façon très claire
que ceux qui héritent
des promesses éternelles
sont ceux qui ont la foi
et la persévérance.
Alors,
comment comprendre cela ?
Comment on peut être
à la fois allergique
au salut
par la foi
plus les mérites
et en même temps
à ce que l'apôtre
ici dit
que ceux qui vont
hériter des promesses éternelles
sont ceux qui ont
la foi
et la persévérance.
nous l'avons expliqué
lors des dernières prédications
notamment de Nathaniel
que je vous invite
à réécouter
sur l'épître de Jacques.
En réalité,
ce n'est pas un problème
si difficile à résoudre
à la lumière
de la parole de Dieu
parce que l'apôtre
utilise
la foi
et la persévérance
comme une définition
de la vraie foi.
Celui qui met
véritablement sa foi
en Christ,
c'est celui
qui va naturellement
persévérer.
Voilà la manifestation
de la vraie foi
et en faisant ainsi,
il exclut de la vraie foi
toutes les foies
qui se basent
simplement sur des professions.
En associant
la persévérance
à la vraie foi,
l'auteur est en train
d'exclure
les foies éphémères,
les foies professionnelles,
les foies traditionnelles,
les foies rituelles
et il est en train
de définir
qu'est-ce que
la vraie foi salvatrice.
La vraie foi salvatrice
va se manifester
par la persévérance
si nous sommes sauvés
et ça nous disons
un grand amène
à cette vérité
en tant que protestants,
si nous sommes sauvés
par le seul moyen
de la foi
en Jésus-Christ
seul,
la foi
ne vient jamais seule.
La vraie foi salvatrice
est celle
qui produit
des fruits
en nous.
C'est celle
qui nous pousse
à nous attacher
aux promesses de Dieu
et qui les fait sienne.
La foi salvatrice
est celle
qui est consciente
de son désespoir
et qui court
vers Jésus-Christ
comme seule espérance.
La foi salvatrice
est celle
qui saisit
la parole de Dieu
et qui s'approprie
les promesses de Dieu
en toutes circonstances.
Voilà la foi salvatrice.
C'est celle
qui persévère
année après année
dans les promesses
de Dieu.
Notre foi
peut être vacillante,
oui,
et elle l'a été
pour certains des auditeurs.
Mais,
comme l'a dit
un pasteur un jour,
notre foi
n'est pas la nôtre
pour que nous puissions
la perdre.
La foi
est un don de Dieu.
La vraie foi salvatrice,
c'est celle
que Dieu communique
généreusement,
gratuitement,
pour l'éternité.
Et la vraie foi salvatrice
est celle
qui va persévérer
de façon
inévitable.
Et donc,
l'appel ici
de l'apôtre,
c'est de vivre
conformément
à cette vraie foi salvatrice
en mêlant votre foi
à la persévérance.
Il semble
qu'ici,
dans ce passage,
et on l'a entendu
depuis l'introduction,
les chants
et les offrandes,
l'auteur fixe
les regards
des auditeurs
vers les choses éternelles,
vers la perspective éternelle.
Et la raison
pour laquelle
il fait ça,
c'est qu'il semblerait
que les auditeurs
soient plutôt
maintenant attachés
aux choses de cette terre.
Que ce soit,
d'ailleurs,
des choses
qui peuvent être saintes,
c'est-à-dire
l'ancienne sacrificature,
les traditions
que Dieu a données
au peuple d'Israël,
eh bien,
il semble que maintenant
leur intérêt est plutôt
sur les choses de la terre.
Et leur confiance
semble être plutôt
dans ses moyens.
Alors que ces choses
étaient des ombres
jusqu'au temps
de la réformation,
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à ce que
Christ vienne
et que toute la lumière soit.
Quelque chose
d'intéressant à noter,
je ne vais pas perdre
trop de temps dessus
parce que le temps
passe déjà rapidement,
mais le temple,
la cour,
le tabernacle,
le sacerdoce
qui a été donné
à Moïse de voir
sur le mont Sinaï,
il est dit
dans le chapitre d'Hébreu
plus tard,
et ça va être
un argument très fort,
lorsque Dieu a révélé
ces choses à Moïse,
Dieu a révélé à Moïse
selon le modèle
qui lui a été donné
de voir.
Autrement dit,
même ce que Moïse
était en train
d'inculquer au peuple
n'était pas
la fin des choses.
C'était un réplica
de ce que Moïse
a vu
sur cette montagne.
Ce n'était pas
la fin des choses.
Cessez de mettre
votre confiance
dans des choses terrestres.
Laissez ces éléments
qui présentaient Christ
et maintenant,
chers chrétiens,
avancez chaque jour
dans les réalités éternelles
qui ne sont pas périssables,
qui ne sont pas caduques.
Et après la charité
que vous avez montrée
envers les chrétiens
du verset 9,
eh bien maintenant,
soyez déterminés
à grandir
dans la foi.
Et dans ce voyage
de persévérance,
nous allons maintenant
voir dans ces courts versets
comment l'auteur
nous prépare.
Ce n'est pas une marche
naïve.
Allez, ça va aller.
Soyez encouragés maintenant.
L'auteur nous prépare
à la nature combative
de la persévérance.
Il veut que nous soyons
au courant du combat
dans lequel nous allons
tous rentrer.
Il ne veut pas
que nous soyons naïfs
et que nous abordions
ce combat,
la fleur au fusil.
Et voyons maintenant
quelques caractéristiques
qui sont données aux chrétiens
pour qu'ils soient préparés
à la nature combative
de l'espérance.
Premièrement,
la persévérance doit être animée
par un zèle.
Verset 11,
relisons ensemble.
Nous désirons que chacun
de vous montre
le même zèle
pour conserver jusqu'à la fin
une pleine espérance.
Et ici,
il semble que le pour
dans ce verset,
donc pour conserver
jusqu'à la fin
une pleine espérance,
vise à montrer
l'objet vers lequel
le zèle doit être déployé.
Votre zèle
doit être déployé
pour la conservation
de votre pleine espérance.
voyez dans le passé,
et là,
je reprends le verset 9,
voyez la diligence,
la générosité
avec laquelle
vous avez aidé les saints.
Voyez le volontariat
avec lequel
dans vos premières heures
d'éveil spirituel,
votre générosité,
votre zèle
pourrait conforter
celui qui connaissait
la persécution
et qui était pour certains
d'entre eux-mêmes
emprisonné.
Voyez votre passion,
voyez ce zèle
dévorant que vous avez
dans votre cœur
en manifestant
votre générosité,
votre charité
envers les enfants de Dieu.
Eh bien,
faites part
de ce même zèle,
mais maintenant,
appliquez-le
pour grandir
dans votre foi.
Voilà,
en substance,
la signification
du verset 11.
Nous désirons
que chacun de vous
montre le même zèle
pour conserver
jusqu'à la fin
une pleine espérance.
Oui,
les auditeurs,
comme je l'ai dit,
ont été connus
pour leurs œuvres
remarquables
aux premières heures
de leur vie chrétienne.
Ce n'est pas juste
un auditoire
que nous devrions
mépriser,
au contraire.
Ils ont fait preuve
d'une grande endurance
dans les premières heures
et d'une grande audace
de leur vie chrétienne,
beaucoup de courage.
Et ils étaient connus
pour un amour
grandissant pour les saints
qui se manifestait
par toutes sortes
de générosités.
Pourquoi étiez-vous connus,
vous, personnellement,
dans les premières heures
de votre vie chrétienne ?
Pour quelles ailes
étaient-vous connus ?
Étiez-vous connus
pour le zèle
pour partager l'évangile ?
Étiez-vous connus
par ceux qui vous entourez
pour un zèle
pour aider les saints,
pour servir à l'église,
pour porter assistance
même dans le secret ?
Étiez-vous connus
pour endurer les moqueries
et passer outre
les mépris
de ceux qui vous entourent ?
Étiez-vous connus
pour une certaine piété
au-dessus de la norme
dans votre vie spirituelle ?
Étiez-vous connus
pour votre générosité secrète ?
Eh bien,
ne vous arrêtez pas maintenant.
Employez ce même zèle
pour laquelle vous avez été
particulièrement remarquable
et appliquez-le maintenant
pour avancer dans la foi.
Appliquez-le maintenant
pour grandir
dans la perception
des promesses à venir.
Conservez,
appliquez ce zèle
pour conserver
les espérances à venir
constamment devant vos yeux.
Appliquez ce même zèle
pour maintenir,
jour après jour,
la perspective de l'éternité
devant vos yeux.
Montrez de la diligence
pour que vos esprits,
l'esprit de vos épouses,
l'esprit de vos enfants
soient saturés
des promesses éternelles
de Dieu.
Montrez ce zèle.
Soyez disciplinés,
jour après jour,
pour maintenir
cette perspective
de l'éternité
et que vos actions
traduisent
vos véritables convictions.
Montrez ce même zèle.
Vous avez du zèle
pour tellement de choses.
pour parcourir
des kilomètres
et des kilomètres.
Vous avez du zèle
pour dépenser
beaucoup d'énergie
dans certains objectifs,
certaines activités.
Vous avez du zèle
pour dépenser
même des ressources
conséquentes
dans certains objectifs.
Faites preuve
de ce même zèle
pour conserver
jusqu'à la fin
votre pleine espérance.
Mon frère, ma sœur,
si les promesses de Dieu
vous paraissent incertaines,
si la vision de l'éternité
n'est pas constamment
devant vos yeux,
faites preuve
du même zèle
que vous aviez
pour vous appliquer
à garder cette perspective
constamment
devant vos yeux.
La persévérance
est animée par un zèle
mais c'est aussi
un exercice
qui s'oppose
à l'immobilisme.
Et c'est ce que
l'auteur nous dit ici
afin que vous ne
vous relâchiez point.
Il oppose
la conservation
de l'espérance
au relâchement.
Autrement dit,
si vous voulez
que votre espérance
à venir,
la conservation
de votre pleine assurance
pour les choses à venir
disparaisse,
vous n'avez rien à faire.
Si vous voulez
que la perception
de la beauté
des promesses de Dieu
soit toujours vibrante
dans votre cœur,
vous n'avez rien à faire.
Si vous voulez
perdre de vue
la perspective
de l'éternité,
la vie éternelle,
la gloire de Dieu
et que tout cela
perde sa saveur,
vous n'avez rien à faire.
La conservation
de l'espérance
s'oppose
à l'immobilisme.
Comme la gravité
terrestre
fait approcher
tout objet terrestre
vers le centre
de la terre
sans effort,
sans manipulation
humaine,
eh bien,
à cause de notre
nature déchue,
les promesses de Dieu,
la beauté de Christ
s'évapore
si nous ne la
nourrissons pas
par un zèle.
Il faut que nous
soyons actifs,
mes frères et sœurs.
Il faut que nous
soyons actifs.
Celui qui se relâche,
en réalité,
ne fait rien d'actif.
C'est celui
qui laisse ses heures
passer,
celui qui laisse
ses journées
passer,
celui qui laisse
ses semaines
passer,
celui qui cède
dans la lutte
de sa chair
pour être sous
l'influence
du Saint-Esprit,
au travers des réunions,
au travers de la prière,
au travers de la méditation
de la parole de Dieu.
Un tel homme
perdra automatiquement
une pleine assurance
dans l'espérance
des choses à venir.
Il n'y a rien
d'étonnant
à cause de notre
nature corrompue.
Et c'est la raison
pour laquelle
celui qui cherche Dieu
ou celui qui veut
être renouvelé
dans son zèle
pour les choses de Dieu
ne va pas se contenter
de faire une prière
à Dieu et ensuite
d'attendre que
la pluie tombe.
Et quelque part,
ce genre de pratique
spirituelle,
pour nombre
d'entre nous,
ont laissé des traces
dans notre discipline
spirituelle encore aujourd'hui
en attendant que Dieu
nous renouvelle
de façon miraculeuse
et instantanée.
Non, celui qui cherche Dieu,
celui qui cherche
à être
à nouveau zélé
et quelqu'un qui marche
et quelqu'un qui court
et quelqu'un qui s'expose
à tous les endroits
où il sera influencé
par le Saint-Esprit
en lui.
Il imite Jacob
qui se battra
jusqu'à être béni
par Dieu.
Il imite les aveugles
qui, avec la conviction
d'être bénis par Jésus-Christ,
ne font aucun cas
des moqueries de la foule
et s'avancent
vers Jésus-Christ.
C'est un exercice difficile.
C'est un exercice actif
que délevé constamment,
jour après jour,
nos esprits vers le ciel.
Tant notre nature
nous tire constamment
vers le bas.
Ce n'est pas une surprise,
mes frères et sœurs,
que le vendredi soir,
vous soyez fatigués
avant de venir
à la réunion de prière.
Ne soyez pas accablés
par ce sentiment,
c'est tout à fait normal.
C'est la réalité
de tout chrétien.
Il n'est pas surprenant
que lorsque vous devez prier,
vous vous sentiez découragé
et vous trouvez
mille autres occupations
à faire.
C'est exactement
ce que nous présente
l'auteur.
C'est tout à fait normal.
En revanche,
nous devons être conscients
de l'aspect combatif
de la persévérance
pour pouvoir y répondre
de façon appropriée,
pour que vous ne soyez pas
surpris vous-même
de la propre difficulté.
Maintenant,
comment...
Je vais avancer.
Je disais à mon épouse
que j'ai déjà effacé
un cinquième,
voire un quart
de la prééducation,
mais je vais encore devoir
sauter quelques points.
Mais l'auteur,
on peut se poser maintenant
la question,
nous avons saisi
la nature combative
de cette persévérance
qui est endurante,
qui consiste à conserver,
qui consiste à avoir du zèle,
qui consiste à être actif
jour après jour
pour notre famille,
pour notre propre âme.
Maintenant,
comment le faire ?
Comment persévérer ?
Quels sont les moyens
que la Bible nous donne ?
Et nous n'allons pas
traiter tous les moyens
de grâce,
ce qu'on appelle,
vous l'avez entendu
dans les prières,
dans l'introduction,
les moyens de grâce,
c'est-à-dire
les moyens ordinaires
ordinaires
par lesquels
Dieu décide
de faire descendre
les bénédictions
réservées en Christ
à son peuple ?
Donc nous n'allons pas
étudier tous les moyens
ordinaires que Dieu nous donne
pour renouveler
notre espérance,
nous allons simplement voir
ce que l'auteur nous propose
dans ses versets.
Verset 12.
Quel est le moyen
que l'auteur utilise
pour persévérer ?
Quels sont les moyens
qu'il nous donne
pour que nous avancions
dans la foi ?
En sorte que vous ne
vous relâchez point
et que vous imitiez
ceux qui,
par la foi
et la persévérance,
héritent des promesses.
Voilà un moyen
extraordinaire
que Dieu nous donne
d'être renouvelés
dans notre zèle
pour la persévérance,
d'imiter nos frères
et sœurs dans la foi,
d'imiter ceux
qui nous ont précédés
et qui ont hérité
des promesses
par la foi
et la persévérance.
Nous avons la même foi
qu'eux.
Nous avons la même profession
de foi
que ceux qui nous ont précédés
il y a des siècles.
Nous chantons
le même contenu,
nous prions
les mêmes contenus
et bien imiter aussi
leur foi
et leur persévérance.
Eux aussi,
lorsque l'Évangile
leur a été présenté
où qu'ils soient,
dans leur royaume,
dans leur tribu même,
dans leurs empires
où ils étaient,
nos frères dans la foi,
eux aussi,
quand l'Évangile
leur a été présenté
dans toute leur beauté,
la beauté de Christ
a transversé leur cœur.
Eux aussi,
comme vous,
vous qui faites
profession de foi
véritable,
eux aussi,
leurs yeux ont été
attirés sur les choses
éternelles.
Eux aussi,
dans leurs heures
d'éveil spirituel,
et bien même la souffrance
leur paraît endurable.
tout leur paraissait
insignifiant.
Pourquoi m'enrichir
sur cette terre ?
Pourquoi travailler
tous les jours
pour m'enrichir
alors que mes trésors
sont célestes ?
Eux aussi,
mes frères et sœurs,
à cause de leur désir
d'être saints
et de marcher
dans la piété,
ont connu
l'imitié du monde,
l'animosité
des gens
qui les entourent.
Et eux aussi,
certainement,
ont été tiraillés
entre la poursuite
dans la sainteté
et restés
dans le confort.
Pourtant,
ils ont fait preuve
de foi
et de persévérance.
Ils se sont attachés
à la provision
céleste de Dieu,
Jésus-Christ,
et ils ont persévéré
avec zèle
jusqu'à la fin.
Nous avons eu le privilège
il y a quelques mois
avec mon épouse
d'aller au musée
du désert
qui se situe
dans le sud
de la France
et qui retrace
l'histoire
des huguenots
en France.
Et je vous invite
vraiment
à considérer
l'héritage protestant
que nous avons
en France
et que notre zèle
soit restaurée
par l'exemple
de nos frères
qui nous ont précédés
dans la foi.
Et à un moment,
la guide
qui nous menait
dans ce musée
nous a dit
« Eh bien,
ils ont fait preuve
d'un zèle incroyable,
ces jeunes huguenots.
Mais aujourd'hui,
les situations
sont un peu différentes
et la religion
est un petit peu
différente aujourd'hui.
Alors,
évidemment,
c'est normal
qu'on n'ait pas
le même zèle. »
C'est précisément
l'opposé
que nous dit
l'auteur ici.
Imiter le zèle,
la foi,
la persévérance
de ceux
qui sont héritiers
des promesses.
Nous avons,
mes frères et sœurs,
la même espérance
que ces jeunes français
du XVIIe
et du XVIIIe siècle
qui,
et qui,
!
qui,
ses parents
l'ont supplié
d'abandonner
sa quête vaine.
Et il répondit
à ses parents
« Le Seigneur m'appelle
à sceller sa vérité
par mon propre sang.
Ne me privez pas
de ma couronne. »
Nous partageons
la même espérance
que nos frères et sœurs.
Imitons la foi
et la persévérance
de ceux qui nous ont précédés.
Que notre léthargie,
que notre paresse
puisse sembler
encore plus risible
à la lecture
de ce que nos frères
ont enduré
pour la même confession
de foi que vous.
Pour le même attachement
à la même espérance.
Et nous savons
que l'immense majorité
des martyrs chrétiens,
leur histoire
n'a pas eu l'honneur
d'être écrite.
Mais le Seigneur
n'oublia aucun d'entre eux.
Le Seigneur n'oublia
aucune des œuvres.
Et leur honneur
qui leur est réservé
est énorme.
Et la Bible
nous présente
cette perspective.
L'honneur réservé
à ceux qui ont eu
la tête coupée
en nom de Dieu.
est énorme,
est infini.
Mais pour ceux
dont l'histoire
a été écrite,
que ce soit dans la Bible
surtout,
mais que ce soit
par la providence
de Dieu pour nous,
le souvenir du juste
est en bénédiction
pour nous aujourd'hui.
oui,
l'histoire de l'Église protestante
protestante,
où l'histoire des martyrs
n'est pas un exercice
qui est réservé
à l'élite de l'Église chrétienne,
aux intellectuels
de l'Église.
C'est précisément
une ordonnance
qui est donnée à tous
dans le verset.
Imiter la foi
et la persévérance
de ceux qui ont hérité
les promesses.
Et que par cette étude,
eh bien,
leur courage
puisse nous être
comme un fusé.
que leur endurance
puisse être pour nous
les nouveaux standards
de notre endurance.
Les kilomètres
que nous devons parcourir
pour assister au culte
puissent être
comme risibles
devant ce qu'ils ont connu.
Que leur audace
puisse être notre standard.
Que leur endurance
puisse être un exemple
pour nous
dont nous sommes
fiers d'imiter.
Et comme je l'ai dit,
que notre immobilise,
que notre paresse
puisse nous paraître
encore plus risible.
Nous allons conclure.
Nous avons vu
comment persévérer
avec un des moyens
de grâce
qui nous a été donné.
Et maintenant,
l'auteur
veut nous mener
vers quoi persévérer.
Parce que jusqu'à maintenant,
nous avons parlé
de la nature combative
de cette persévérance,
de son importance
de persévérer,
de comment persévérer,
mais vers quoi persévérer.
Quelle est cette espérance?
L'espérance chrétienne
n'a pas la même utilisation
que le mot espérance
dans le langage courant.
Relisons ensemble
verset 11
pour être imprégnés
du texte.
Donc,
nous désirons que chacun
de vous montre
le même zèle
pour conserver jusqu'à la fin
une pleine espérance.
Mais quelle est cette espérance?
L'espérance chrétienne
n'a rien à voir
avec le langage courant
du mot espérance
aujourd'hui.
L'espérance chrétienne
n'est pas quelque chose
qui peut arriver
ou peut ne pas arriver.
Non.
Les Écritures nous enseignent
par rapport
à ce mot espérance.
Et ce que nous retirons
de cette étude
du mot espérance
c'est que l'espérance
pour les chrétiens
est quelque chose
de sûr et de certain.
Par contre,
c'est une réalité
qu'il ne peut pas voir encore
et qu'il verra
lorsqu'il passera
les portes de la mort.
Mais ces choses
sont sûres
et certaines
parce qu'elles reposent
sur les promesses
de Dieu lui-même.
Ce sont des choses
qu'il ne peut pas voir
encore de ses yeux
mais qui sont aussi réelles
que tout ce que vous pouvez voir
et toucher aujourd'hui.
Mes frères et sœurs,
cela est admirable
de nous rappeler
que votre demeure éternelle
qui vous est réservée
pour ceux qui ont mis
leur foi pleine
en Jésus-Christ
est aussi réelle
que votre habitation
fait de ciment
et de briques.
La gloire éternelle
de Dieu
est aussi réelle
que les rayons de soleil
que nous pouvons voir.
Le rassemblement des saints
de toute l'histoire
avec les Huguenots,
avec les premiers martyrs,
est tout aussi réelle
que le rassemblement des saints
que nous avons ce matin.
C'est là notre espérance.
Jésus-Christ sera manifesté
devant nos yeux
comme nous l'avons introduit
dans l'Apocalypse 22
de façon sûre et certaine.
C'est une réalité
encore plus réelle
que ce que nous pouvons voir
aujourd'hui.
Et c'était la conviction
des martyrs.
Lorsque les gris
dans les arènes se levaient
et que les lions s'apprêtaient
à les dévorer vivants,
c'était leur espérance
quand ils continuaient
à chanter des psaumes.
L'espérance de quelque chose
de sûr et de certain.
Passer les portes
de la mort,
je retrouverai mon sauveur.
La mort m'éteint
car je sais
ce qui m'attend derrière.
Voilà le zèle
qui devrait être
le nôtre.
Et ces martyrs
n'ont pas été dupés.
Ces martyrs n'ont pas été
trompés.
Ils forment maintenant
cette nuée de témoins
qui chantent
le triomphe
de la grâce de Dieu.
Et ils disent
le Seigneur
nous a véritablement donné
ce qu'il nous avait promis.
Le Seigneur
n'est pas un menteur
et cette nuée
de témoins
est en train
de nous regarder
aujourd'hui
courant dans ce stade.
Voilà ce que Hébreu
expliquera
au chapitre suivant.
Nous sommes environnés
d'une nuée
de témoins.
Les héros de la foi.
Abraham nous regarde,
Moïse nous regarde,
les Huguenots
vous regardent.
Ils chantent
le triomphe
de la grâce.
Dans les milieux
chrétiens,
même parfois protestants
pour être tout à fait
honnête avec nous,
nous parlons
du mot espérance
et même du mot promesse
sans lui attacher
quelque chose
de défini.
Nous restions bien vagues
sur ce mot promesse
et on chante des chants
« ta promesse en moi
c'est l'encre de ma foi »
sans définir
quel est ce mot promesse.
et finalement
les gens finissent
par mettre
dans les promesses de Dieu
tout ce que leur cœur désire
en pensant que
c'est les promesses de Dieu.
Non,
mes frères et sœurs,
notre espérance repose
sur les promesses de Dieu
qu'il nous a laissés
dans sa parole.
Voilà notre assurance.
Le même Dieu
qui a créé le monde
en parlant
a agencé l'histoire,
il nous a promis
les choses éternelles
et nous devons
nous fier,
mettre notre foi,
mêler notre foi
à la parole de Dieu.
Vous savez que mon épouse
et moi-même
nous attendons
depuis notre mariage
des enfants.
Est-ce que le Seigneur
nous a promis
que nous serions
comme Abraham
des pères des nations ?
Ce n'est pas une promesse
que Dieu nous a faite.
Et pourtant,
nous continuons de prier
comptant sur la grâce de Dieu.
Mais ce n'est pas une promesse
que Dieu nous a faite.
vous qui pouvez être atteint
par la maladie,
par la souffrance,
est-ce que comme le roi
Ézéchias,
Dieu vous a fait
une promesse directe
que Dieu allait vous guérir ?
Peut-être pas.
Par contre,
la Bible est remplie
de promesses
qui sont bien supérieures
au fait d'avoir des enfants,
au fait d'avoir
une santé sainte,
saine.
La Bible est remplie,
la Bible est saturée
de promesses
pour le chrétien.
Et je vous inviterai maintenant
pour conclure
à courber la tête.
Et je vais lire pour vous
certaines promesses
dans un esprit de prière.
Et je vous invite,
alors que vous entendez
chacune des promesses
que je vais citer,
à être décidés,
à exercer votre foi
pour conserver
cette pleine espérance.
Et voici,
je serai avec vous
tous les jours
jusqu'à la fin du monde.
Toutes choses concourent
au bien
de ceux qui aiment Dieu.
Voilà
où doit être
notre espérance.
Ceux qu'il a appelés,
il les a justifiés.
Ceux qu'il a justifiés,
il les a glorifiés.
Vous aurez des tribulations
dans le monde,
mais prenez courage,
j'ai vaincu le monde.
Venez à moi,
vous tous qui êtes fatigués
et chargés,
et je vous donnerai
du repos.
Et voici,
pour finir,
une des promesses
les plus surprenantes,
tant par sa simplicité
que par ce qu'elle promet,
ce qu'elle garantit.
Celui qui croit
au Fils éternel,
à la vie éternelle.
Le seul espoir
de l'humanité
pour le plus grand
des pécheurs,
des fornicateurs,
pour la plus sale
des prostituées,
pour le plus grand
des meurtriers,
celui qui croit
au Fils,
à la vie éternelle.
Toutes ces promesses
sont scellées à jamais
par le sang
de votre médiateur,
Jésus-Christ lui-même.